the creepiest thing I've ever seen in my
life
how to make candidates more likeable
maybe they could dress up as like Disney
characters I could do a few debates as
Disney Princesses Beach he'll stop
caring about being the president that's
how you become president oh hey girl
it's Hillary Clinton nobody's been
elected president without eyeballs oh I
think people think she's a little fierce
so what if we put a kitty I bet I back
this Saturday right
yeah y'all took people a lot these would
make Chris Christie more cuddly
everybody's got scandal I'm gonna wear
it I'm gonna own this bridge oh I wish I
had a Santa hat cuz like if Chris
Christie gave people toys I think that
would help a lot so here is my revamped
Chris Christie well well well who do we
have here okay mmm-hmm oh god no oh
Jesus this candidate is Donald Trump
so let's hide that hair that'll make you
more likeable put some glue under here
too just like your normal hair everyday
so Donald Trump needs some perspective
in life I wanted him to be in someone
else's skin granted no one has this skin
but now he does now he's different he's
another and he has to deal with it who
is the best of kid who put eyeballs on
everyone it's terrifying
who did that I'm gonna find you I think
if I were to give actual advice to them
I would say just be more honest you
should be sincere you should be
passionate about what you believe in
Konya 2020 right
[Music]